a forest of pipes and cylinders and a
Windswept piece of Atlantic Coastline
marks the spot where Ireland's only
source of natural gas is processed first
discovered in 1996 the Carib gas field
lies around 50 miles off County Mayo's
Coast the extracted gas is then piped to
the Ballina boy terminal
the problem is the gas brought ashore
here accounts for just 30 percent or so
of Ireland's gas supply the other 70
percent is imported by a pipeline from
the United Kingdom meaning that Ireland
is hugely dependent on Britain for its
crucial energy needs
and with warnings of a potential gas
shortage in Britain over the winter
Ireland's vulnerability is acute when
we're at the mercy of uh British uh
companies in terms of supplying gas I
mean clearly we have to have some form
of agreement with the UK government with
UK gas suppliers that in the event of
there being a shortage that we would
still be supplied gas and that clearly
makes us very vulnerable
people here are already worried about
energy security this winter an hour from
the gas terminal this meals on Wheel
service in Ballina has seen its bills
Rise by around 300 Euro a month and the
impact price hikes have had on its
mostly elderly users they're stretched
to the left and the fear the fear is in
it when they when you speak to them they
say oh will we survive the winter when
we have the heat we will be able to keep
ourselves warm good afternoon
one of the services 40 users is 88 year
old Helen O'Connor originally from
Yorkshire I don't move about very fast
therefore I don't keep warm very quickly
so I tend to put an extra one and an
extra one and a blanket uh
it's
not that easy I'm trying to be very
economical on myself from every point of
view not just from my bill but from the
the planet's sake not to use more fuel
than a must the National Grade in the UK
says Irish consumers will be treated the
same as those in Britain in any Supply
emergency but that hasn't reassured
those raising the alarm Ireland urgently
needs to diversify its energy supplies
as its only indigenous source of gas
starts to deplete until then to its
nearest neighbor Ireland will remain a
friend in need Stephen Murphy Sky News
in County Mayo